à proximité de la chaufferie biomasse le
nouveau forage halal bien de saint
germain en laye à trois objectifs
transférer l'ancien forage situé au pecq
ce fourrage est en fait il découle d'un
ancien forage qui existait au pec qui
n'est plus exploité aujourd'hui réaliser
la valorisation thermique de l'eau on
valorise la chaleur l'eau elle ressort à
28 degrés de ce forage 28 degrés c'est
trop chaud pour être redistribuées donc
nous on extrait les calories ont fait
baisser la chaleur et cette chaleur
récupérée ont l'art et injecte dans le
réseau de chaleur et sécuriser
l'approvisionnement en eau potable pour
les saint germanois à travers la mise en
place de ce forage l albien nous
maîtrisons 40% de nos consommations
d'eau et c'est très important d'avoir
des capacités de maîtriser ces flux
parce que c'est aussi la maîtrise des
prix de l'eau plus tard la nappe
phréatique de l'albien est situé à
environ 627 m sous terre le coût total
des travaux s'élève à un peu plus de 5
millions d'euros on est sur un budget
est conséquent avec 5 millions d'euros
de subventions publiques l' agence de
l'eau l'ademe celle agence pour la
maîtrise de l'énergie la région
ile-de-france cas voilà était un
partenaire de tous les instants et puis
des partenaires économiques parce que la
particularité de ce progrès c'est que
c'est du public et du privé donc la
société saur et puis la banque des
territoires c'est à dire la caisse du
dépôts et consignations qui est
également notre partenaire au capital de
cette société d'économie mixte 2 en 1 la
chaleur de l'eau permettra de fournir
6800 mégawattheure de chaleur aux
habitants puis 16 1200 mégawatts heure
en 2024 cette nouvelle source de chaleur
permettra à la ville de saint germain
les d'étendre sa part d'énergie
renouvelable a quasiment 80 %